[Música]
k
Boa noite a todos é um prazer estar com
vocês
novamente vamos responder as dúvidas
hoje eu não preparei artigos ficar
devendo para vocês eu acabei
esquecendo à medida que vocês forem
entrando por favor de o seu Boa noite me
digam se o áudio está
legal bem vou abrir aqui o arquivo com
as
dúvidas primeira
pergunta Existe alguma
contraindicação para o uso de Ach gand e
rodiola juntos pela pela amanhã boa
noite taquinha né Maria
Helena A princípio não tem
contraindicação de usar chagando e
rodiola de manhã não vejo nenhum
problema tá mas sempre é interessante
você ter uma acompanha
de um médico para poder estar fazendo
uso disso na falta de um médico você
pode est utilizando em doses baixas né E
tá sentindo como é que é a reação do seu
organismo Na verdade essa combinação
pode ser benéfica para muitas pessoas é
muito bom para gerenciar o estresse
aumentar a energia melhorar o bem-estar
geral algumas pessoas têm sensibilidade
achando ou
rodiola obviamente mulheres grávidas ou
amamentando não devem
utilizar alguns medicamentos por exemplo
se você tá tomando remédio para baixar
açúcar do sangue e já está controlado o
uso concomitante da ch Ganda pode
reduzir mais ainda os níveis de glicose
Então tem que fazer ajustes nos
medicamentos de açúcar no sangue Se isso
for o caso Às vezes a chag também pode
baixar a pressão arterial em pessoas
mais sensíveis tem que ficar atento com
isso aí
raramente a chagada também interfere com
medicamentos que suprimem o sistema
imune ou medicamentos hipnóticos ou
sedativos a rodiola também é bem
tolerada mas pode causar tonturas
ressecamento da boca Produções excessiva
de saliva em algumas
pessoas Então tem que tomar só Cuidado
com essas situações que eu falei
aqui próxima pergunta para quem tem herp
zoster e utiliza vala ciclovir um
tratamento pode usar lisina ou teria
algum outro suplemento a lisina é mais
para herp
simples Lógico que o herp zosta que o
vírus da catapora tem muita semelhança
com o vírus do herp
simples mas se você tiver uma crise
mesmo de ep zoster aí eu sugiro usar
mesmo é vala ciclovir a lisina já não é
tão estudada nessa
circunstância Ok então Apesar de eu
achar interessante porque a lisina
também é aminoácido que tem efeito
calmante
neuroprotetor é só entender que a lisina
é para mais herpes simples e não tanto
para herpes Hoster Ok só lembrar
disso algum outros suplementos que podem
ajudar na saúde geral na imunidade é o
extrato de óleo de Oliveira A vitamina C
A equinácea o
zinco
ômega-3 vitamina D de
dado o próprio eh extrato de alguns
congumelos também que ajudam na
imunidade próxima pergunta gostaria de
saber em relação ao contraste no uso de
exam de imagem se o senhor é contra ou a
favor depende tá eu não sou radicalmente
contra contraste Esse é um tema complexo
tem que entender o risco e benefício né
o contraste pode ter problema
sim pode ter problema de alergia em
alguns casos até de intoxicação
os mais comuns é o iodo né o o contraste
iodado o de gadolínio que é de
ressonância e o de báo que é usado para
eed né que aquele estudo esse exame é
menos feito hoje em dia mas é o estudo
estômago esôfago do oden né um exame
radiológico que hoje é pouco
utilizado Além da questão da reação
alérgica pessoas que TM suficiência
renal podem ter muita sensibilidade
contraste iodado né pessoas diabéticas
também podem ter efeitos
adversos Então tem que ser bem analisado
se o contraste É realmente necessário
por exemplo vários casos de pacientes
que têm suspeito de cálculo urinário às
vezes não é necessário fazer uso de
contraste e oado
somente o uso aí
do do raio x sem contraste né a
tomografia sem contraste pode ser o
suficiente Ok então não é nem sempre ao
mar nem sempre a
terra próxima pergunta uma mulher tem
mais de 50 anos de idade diabetes e faz
tempo que mediu e não faz dieta mas toma
berberina 500 mg duas ou três vezes ao
dia o fato dela tomar berberina compensa
não não compensa ajuda mas não compensa
ou é perigoso não perigoso não é
perigoso é ela ficar né nessa situação
aí de sem controlar o açúcar do sangue
ok
então a situação é essa vocês tem que
ficar atento não é só tomar a
berberina precisa fazer uma dieta
adequada atividade física bons hábitos
de vida
né a beberina ela não é Milagrosa ela
ajuda bastante ela é parecida com a
metiformina
ela vai ajudar a baixar os níveis de
glicose ajudar a melhorar a
sensibilidade a insulina reduzir a
produção de glicose no fígado também tem
um efeito intestinal da beberina ela
modula a microbiota né o microbioma
intestinal mas ela não compensa
completamente uma dieta que não seja
saudável um estilo de vida ruim
Ok então não é para fazer somente uso de
beberina precisa melhorar a dieta
atividade física fazer um gjo
intermitente né controlar o estresse
melhorar o sono tudo que nós falamos aí
sempre nesse
canal próxima
pergunta vi que D Alan dultra indicou a
orgânico natural eu já conheci essa
marca mas nunca comprei nada ainda uma
vez perguntei ao Senhor se conhecia
indicava o senhor disse que nunca tinha
ouvido falar Será que eu nunca talvez
achoi mal entendido eu já tinha ouvido
falar assim tá apó indicar vou começar a
comprar como posso a maca é boa sim eu
já usei os produtos dele eles me
mandaram umas amostras e eu estou vendo
na prática que é um bom produto
tá Como posso ter certeza que essa
máquina não usa produtos prejudiciais
pede um relatório para eles paraa
empresa tá sendo que no Brasil um país
de mentira e engano não só no Brasil viu
isso tem muito fora do Brasil também
como o senhor tem garantias que vocês
são família estão consumindo um produto
livre de aditivos bem eu sinto segurança
com essa marca porque eu usei e
realmente verifiquei que eles são eh um
produto de qualidade natural tá eu usei
um shampoo deles que eu percebi que nem
fazia muito sabão né Isso significa o
quê que não tem que muitos aqueles
aditivos né então eu confio sim mas você
pode pedir um relatório para eles tá
para de qualidade também você pode ir
atrás de selos de qualidade
tá os principais selos tem o selo
orgânico Brasil e o instituto ibd
instituto biodinâmico portant você pode
pedir um desses selos aí que indicam que
o produto atende aos critérios rigorosos
de produção orgânica
certo lei rótulo é sempre muito
importante checar o rótulo e pedir
relatório para
empresa entendeu E também pedir opinião
para outros usuários para
outros internautas que já tinham
utilizado o produto
certo a empresa que é transparente com
processo de produção não vai se
incomodar de mandar o relatório tá de
origem do
produto
beleza próxima
pergunta Dr Alan quando como qualquer
coisa fica um aperto na garganta com um
pouco de catarro às vezes dou um espirro
Zinho leve o que pode ser pode ser
várias coisas né pode ser por exemplo
alergia
alimentar intolerância alimentar pode
ser problema relacionado a glútem leite
caseína né ou a própria lactose ou até
você pode ter alergia aí a um outro
ingrediente como do
ovo da soja do
Milho pode ser qualquer um desses
produtos aí outra possibilidade bastante
comum é o refluxo gastroesofágico né
então esse
sistema de refluxo o áro volta pra
garganta causa irritação desconforto
pode causar tosse e pode causar catarro
também tá então tem que investigar se
você não tá com refluxo gastro
esofágico por exemplo também sinusite ou
rinite pode causar sintomas
semelhantes tá então pode estar se
confundindo aí com o rin sinusite
causado por alergia a pem poeira ou pelo
de animal
Então tem que investigar isso tá ver se
isso daí é uma intolerância ou uma
alergia alimentar ou é glúten ou é
caseína ou é um outro alimento ou se
isso daí não é refluxo ou é renit
sinusite tá Até lá você pode tomar
antioxidantes vitamina C que cetina que
cetina é um excelente
antialérgico natural você pode usar
também bromelina você pode usar também
Ortiga de oica pode usar a camomila
gengibre e procurar uma assistência para
investigação
ah fiz a pergunta sobre orgânico natural
pois após levou S indicando empresa vou
ficar comprando esta empresa número um
na sua lista de empresas Não não vou
dizer que é número um tem a eora que é
muito boa
também eu tem uma lista aqui pessoal
deixa eu abrir essa lista e falar para
vocês porque nem Sempre eu lembro todos
os nomes mas é hora orgânico natural são
muito bons a própria essena
equaliv já vou falar mais alguns nomes
aqui a
própria me dê só um instante aqui que eu
vou abrir o documento
Ué
cadê aqui Pera aí só um
instante a veleda também tem produtos
interessantes
tá a forever também mas a forever é mais
no sentido de ser produtos de
aloa que mais ah tem aquele durante de
prata coloidal D uma cura a Maura tem
uns produtos
interessantes de prata
coloidal macadamia Matrix é outra
empresa que trabalha com produtos à base
de
macadamia tem uma também chamado prema
biocosméticos prema biocosméticos é boa
também tá então tem todas essas empresas
aí para uma pessoa que faz faz sabão
desinfetante e demais produtos de
limpeza e muitas vezes toca sente cheiro
mas o cheiro em si com esses produtos
como lauril formal etc que você
recomenda para prevenção Qual é a dócil
Marina Qual é a máscara Qual é a marca
de máscara que você recomenda e tipo de
luva vamos
lá pessoal quer tudo aqui né vamos lá
primeira prevenção geral é evitar
misturas né não misturar diferentes
produtos de limpeza Porque isso pode
gerar vapores tóxicos compostos
perigosos como acetaldeído quando se
mistura álcool em gel com água sanitária
então se você mistura álcool em gel com
água sanitária pode formar acetaldeído
que é tóxico então evitar isso os olos
equipamento de proteção individual luvas
resistentes a produtos químicos uma maa
muito boa é sempre 3M mas é cara né
também usar máscaras e óculos de
proteção para evitar o contato direto
com a pele inalação de vapores tóxicos
as melhores são as luvas de nitrilo ou
de desculpa nitrilo ou látex Ok trabalhe
sempre em ambientes bem arejados bem
ventilados Lave as Mãos frequentemente
com água e sabão após uso os produtos
use máscaras com filtros especiais né as
máscaras
ffp2 ou ffp3
para filtrar partículas finas e vapores
químicos luvas resistentes a químicos né
como eu já falei nitrilo látex também
pode ser butilo ou neoprene tá a cimar
pode usar de 70 a 140 MG por dia
dividido em duas a três doses para poder
ajudar no fígado você pode usar também
Bergamota você pode usar também
alcachofra você pode pode usar também
alfal pooo pode usar tocotrienois tudo
isso ajuda no fígado Man term tá rica em
antioxidantes vai ajudar também beber
bastante água sempre importante então
marcas eu falei da 3M né que a marca
muito boa de máscara tem uma outra marca
chamado drager drager que tem um tio no
ar
tá tem também as marcas de luva ancel ou
mapa ancel com dois l e
an e
mapa
beleza Qual é a dose
K2 para desup artérias com prevenção a
dose que a gente usa no dia a dia de 100
a 200 mg mas tem um estudo que saiu no
European Journal European Heart Journal
European Heart Journal que mulheres
saudáveis na pós-menopausa consumiram
180 microg de vitamina K2 por 3 anos
tiveram retardo e até mesmo regressão de
rigidez arterial n então você pode até
aumentar essa dose até para chegar até
uns 400 mg por dia mas a dose média é de
100 a 200
mg obviamente tem que lembrar também de
ter uma dieta equilibrada em gorduras
saudáveis óleo de coco azeite de oliva
óleo de
macadâmia óleo de de
abacate tipo de óleos saudáveis né
porque você vai ajudar na absorção da K2
usar também alimentos fermentados que
são ricos em vitamina K2 especialmente o
Nat exercícios físicos regulares Uma
Vida Saudável como Vocês bem
sabem
beleza vamos paraa próxima Qual que é o
nível ideal pro fibrinogênio
Ah o nível ideal é tá mais ou menos
entre o segundo e terceiro quartil OK
ela não pode também est muito baixo o
fibrinogênio porque pode levar problemas
de coagulação sangramento hemorragias né
Então as situações que baixam demais o
fibrinogênio é doenças hepáticas por
exemplo doença hepática grave do fígado
né pode reduzir o fibrinogênio o consumo
intravascular disseminado que eu cvd que
é coagulação intravascular disseminada
pode consumir demais o fibrinogênio
alguns medicamentos também como agentes
fibrinolíticos em excesso isotretinoína
que é um remédio para acne né
para espinha no rosto né é o Roacutan l
asparaginase t g cicina ácido valpróico
pode reduzir fibrinogênio
né e estados inflamatórios em geral ou
situações aí de aumento de coagulação no
sangue pode aumentar o fibrinogênio
câncer muitas vezes Aumenta também
fibrinogênio tá inflamação e câncer são
as principais causas de aumento
fibrinogênio
então para manter o fibrinogen nos
níveis adequados segundo terceiro
quartil a dieta rica em nutrientes
essenciais né Como sempre para manter a
saúde do
fígado vitamina e na forma de
tocotrienois Alf lipoico própria cim
Marina
alcachofra que eu já comentei
a Bergamota o extrat Bergamota
né todos esses agentes aí que já foram
comentados né evitar o consumo excessivo
de álcool gerenciar o estresse e
inflamação com prática saudáveis de
vida certo
eh segundo Ribeiro averiguação de
deficiência de vitamina B12 pode ser
feita através do exame de ácido
metilmalônico o Qual deveria estar emre
7 3 122 pois se tiver mais alto
significa B12
deficiente pergunto o exame de B12
realmente não é conclusivo mais ou menos
tá eu peço exame de B12 porque os planos
de saúde geralmente não liberam o ácido
metilmalônico Ok mas ele é mais sensível
sim tá ele é mais sensível mas tem outro
truque tambémm se a B2 estiver ruim
geralmente o volume corpuscular médio
das hassas fica maior tá então VCM fica
Aim de 100 é outro truque também para
ver se a B12 não tá baixa
Ok mas S Sem dúvida O matim malônico é o
marcador mais sensível e
confiável porque ele reflete as
concentrações intracelulares de vitamina
B12 e ele realmente é ao contrário
quanto a B12 está baixa ele sobe tá
então se tiver acima desses is você vai
variar de laboratório para laboratório
também tá não fica preso nesses valores
aí que você
colocou e seu plano de saúde liberar
ótimo senão você vai ter que desembolsar
para poder pagar esse exame e Geralmente
eu não peço porque eu não vejo tanto
problema em pedir a B2 diretamente não e
ver também o vcm
quais seriam as causas de ferritina
abaixo 38 e mulher com 62 anos que não é
vegetariana tem alimentação
balanceada não consomem processados
industrializados glúten nem açúcar então
mulher de 62 anos já tá aproximadamente
10 anos ou mais sem menstruar que é a
principal causa defei na baixa em mulher
né outras causas possíveis de
sangramento sinal crônico então é
importante fazer uma endoscopia
digestiva alta e uma colonoscopia para
ver se não é isso até porque tem que
fazer de rotina mesmo
colonoscopia porque tá aumentando muito
o o a incidência de câncer de intestino
grosso às vezes sangrou muito no passado
e talvez pela menstruação e talvez ainda
não tenha compensado isso é menos
provável né porque 10 anos é mais do que
o suficiente para poder A não ser que
ela parou de menstruar com 55 existe uma
mulher que para de est 55 né Outra causa
de ferritina baixa disbiose intestinal
que pode interferir na absorção de
Ferro hipotiroidismo também pode afetar
a absorção de ferro e algumas doenças
inflamatórias ou infecções crônicas pode
aumentar a demanda de ferro e reduzir os
níveis de
ferritina deficiência de vitamina Cede
de casa também pode atrapalhar a
absorção de Ferro
então fica atento em relação a isso né
então aumentar o consumo de vitamina C
pode
ajudar Ok e a reposição pode ser feita
por via oral ou intramuscular ou
endovenoso né dependendo do Mas se a
fertina tiver digamos assim você colocou
abaixo de 38 mas pode ser 30 né nem nem
sempre é necessário fazer em do venoso
não existe alguma contraindicação em
consumir 15 G de Glutamina por dia
dividido em três doses é uma dose alta
tá é a dose no limite superior né que a
gente vê nos estudos a Glutamina apesar
de não ser aminoácido essencial é
aminoácido muito interessante para
proteger o sistema imune para melhorar o
funcionamento
intestinal ajuda na recuperação pós
exercício eu não sei porque is aqui qu
consumir 15 G eu eu consumiria algo
então de cinco tá
eh mas é o limite superior como eu falei
a suplementação excessiva de Glutamina
pode levar alterações no transporte de
aminoácidos entre os tecidos absorção no
intestino e rins Então pode prejudicar
absorção e Distribuição de outros
aminoácidos pessoas TM sufí renal mais
grave ou sufí hepática pode ter problema
com essa
suplementação todos vocês já sabem da
história do câncer que eu acho que é
exagerada mas se se tiver suspeita de
câncer teria que suspender a
suplementação Glutamina porque
Teoricamente alimenta o câncer Eu acho
isso uma conversa um pouco mal mal
explicada Mas é só a minha
opinião dose elevada de Glutamina pode
dar também gases pode dar dor abdominal
e distensão tá E então tem que tomar
cuidado com essas doses muito altas
aí então eu não sei porque você quer
fazer 15 G mas eu
sugiro que não faça
Tá pera aí parece que eu subi aqui sem
querer
aqui tem mais perguntas aqui sei que tem
alimentos fermentados que tem mais
estamina a veia teria muita liberação
dela se eu fermentar para diminuir
fitatos sim você pode fazer isso você
pode fermentar
os alimentos para reduzir o nível de
estamina isso aí é uma uma
estratégia azul de metileno perde
potência se tomar junto com a coima q10
estudei escutei esse
comentário eu nunca li a respeito disso
não viu Mas também é fácil de resolver
né É só você tomar metilen tomar coisa
10 no outro né eu não vejo grandes
complicações nisso não no recorte de uma
live do betet com o Dr Joarez calegaro
Diz Que vitamina C combinada com sódio
potássio cálcio e magnésio penetra no
cérebro ué vitamina C não tem problema
de penetração no cérebro não
é eu não sei se eu entendi essa
colocação não viu
você você tá ao vivo aí eu não sei nem
quem que fez essa pergunta deixa eu ver
aqui se eu colocar um no individual
aqui pera aí
individual Mas aí tem que ir pra frente
né Pera
aí Não pera aí
Pergunta ué dois de
dois Ah tá pera aí individual tem que
colocar individual aqui
pronto 9 10 11 12
13 14
15 é da Maria Helena pergunta Ela deve
tá ao vivo
Deixa eu olhar aqui
Boa
noite Estela mar já cumprimentei a Maria
Helena boa noite Eloí
Luciana tem uma pergunta dela aqui ao
vivo alergias a ovos pode entupir muito
o nariz exame de ge não deu
nada só foi alergia do tipo tardia né
que é que na vai intolerância IgG
você pode tpir o nariz sim pode pode sim
mas aí não é alergia clássica de iG É
intolerância pro
IgG vitamina C penetra no C sim penetra
Lógico é Localiza e vê aí porque não tô
achando estranha essa história de que
precisa de um monte de mineral para
vitamina C entrar no cérebro acho que
não tá
bem É só para voltar ao assunto da do AZ
metilen com cois 10 eu não achei nada
aqui viu que diga que a com enzima q10
compete com azul de metileno tá mas se
você tá com dúvida disso daí você pode
tomar em horário diferente simples assim
tá
talvez essa história de vitamina NC com
os minerais aí sódio potássio cálcio
magnésio é porque eles falaram Talvez
seja isso eu tô especulando aqui né como
são outros minerais importantes pro
cérebro talvez eles falaram que
essa junção de todos esses elementos e
ajudaria mais no cérebro
tá não que necessita desses minerais
para vitamina sem entrar no cérebro não
é o caso
não pode ser que Facilite a penetração
no cérebro da vitamina C Devido as
bombas iônicas que tem várias células né
que por exemplo tem a bomba de sódio
potássio tpas né tem os canais R MK mas
elas não são essenciais pro pra vitamina
C entrar no cérebro não que ela já entra
sozinha mas talvez esses canais iônicos
ajudem né Talvez seja esse o contexto
que você viu
aí tá
Ah tem uma pergunta do do Antônio Renato
que eu esqueci de de responder aqui pera
aí deixa eu voltar para as perguntas
aqui respostas resumo
Ah você falou que tem dois tipos de
depressão e um deles tem cura e o outro
não tem poderia falar mais sobre isso eu
não lembro ter falar disso
não o que eu falei provavelmente que a
depressão tem um componente inflamatório
que é reversível
e tem um componente que é disfunção de
neurotransmissor agora eu não lembro de
ter falado que um tem cura e outro não
tem cura Acho que não foi isso que eu
falei não
tá Talvez esteja confundindo depressão
maior e depressão refratária que são
conceitos de de quê a depressão maior é
uma depressão que tem sintomas como
tristeza profunda apatia baixa
autoestima incapacidade de sentir prazer
tem a depressão
refratária que os pacientes Não
respondem aos medicamentos convencionais
Talvez seja essa que você tá querendo
dizer que não tem cura refratária não
quer dizer que tem cura ou que tem cura
tá é outro conceito refratária é que não
responde bem aos tratamentos
tá aí nesses casos você pode usar
aquelas terapias menos convencionais
mais como quetamina como
eletroconvulsoterapia
estimulação magnética
transcraniana
tá existe depressões mais leves como é o
caso da distimia n tem a depressão
sazonal tem a depressão atípica que é
tem padrões e sintomas diferentes como
reatividade do m e aumento do
apetite mas não é que é uma uma tem cura
e outra não tem cura não tá todas elas
têm
reversão mas não pode falar exatamente
em cura tá e com medicamento muitas
vezes a pessoa cura sozinha porque ela
melhora a postura dela perante a vida né
mas não é que é curável no sentido
tradicional com remédio esse conceito já
não é tão adequado não
né ã
shampoo da orgânico natural de coco ou
de qualquer marca confiável tem o poder
de beneficiar o cabelo ou só se ingerir
o coco em
óleo não acho que vai ajudar sim no
cabelo viu não é só
ingerindo o óleo
não foi perguntado será verdade o que os
médicos
dizem que a depressão não tem cura só
tratamento aí a resposta sua foi que que
dependia de qual seria É mas eu não
falei no sentido de reversão não de cura
tá a acho que foi esse foi o contexto
que talvez você não tenha entendido
entendeu talvez tenha sido isso daí
então voltando a assunto do Óleo de coco
ele quando é usado diretamente os
cabelos ele ele é bem interessante para
quem tem cabelo seco né só tem que tomar
cuidado quem tem cabelo oleoso
né Lembrando que o óleo de coco é rico
em várias vitaminas lipossolúveis
vitamina a d e e k ele ajuda a penetrar
na cí culando o fio vai hidratar e
nutrir dar
brilho mas ingerindo via oral também é
uma boa o óo de CCO também vai reduzir o
freeze vai dar mais movimento às pontas
do cabelo protege contra o ressecamento
causado pelo shampoo promove a retenção
de umidade nos fios tem ação antifúngica
antibacteriana como vocês já sabem né
Por causa do ácido láurico né da
monolaurina que que tem no óleo de coco
o ácido láurico vira monolaurina no
estômago né E tem ação
antifúngica eu faria o uso dos dois via
oral e no cabelo tá os dois são são
interessantes
ã coloquei no grupo o vídeo do to Juarez
e
betet tá bom mas é o que eu te falei tá
vitamina ca entra no cérebro sem
necessariamente precisar de grandes
coisas Tá talvez esses canais iônicos
dos minerais aí ajudem a entrar mas não
é condição sinequanon paraa vitamina C
entrar no cérebro tá bom mas também não
é tão relevante você vai ter que comer
minerais você vai ter que comer vitamina
C então isso o que que muda na prática
nada né não sei qual é o ponto aí que
você ficou meio impressionado com esse
assunto aí
mas de qualquer forma você tem que
ingerir vitamina C você tem que ingerir
minerais Então por que que você tá
preocupado se a vitamina C vai entrar
sozinha você vai entrar com o mineral
não sei se eu entendi a sua dúvida nesse
sentido tá na prática isso não muda nada
no meu ponto de vista tá cadê o Eliseu
Eliseu não veio
hoje Eliseu não veio hoje Que milagre
hein Eliseu Você tá vivo Eliseu teve
algum problema
aí mais perguntas pessoal vou ficar mais
uns 5 minutos tá
Ah vocês TM que ter uma certa
eh como você
diz atenção um detalhe tá eu tava até
falando isso com um paciente
hoje tem colega que começa a criar assim
umas filigranas por exemplo tem um vídeo
aí da Luci ker com betet também que ela
começou a meter pau na melatonina porque
melatonina tem um monte de efeito
colateral se você tomar uma dose alta de
melatonina vai mesmo eu uso melatonina
há muitos anos e eu vejo que ela sozinha
dificilmente ela resolve insônia
mais de 50% dos casos eu ten que
associar a melatonina com outras coisas
porém eu não vou usar doses altas de
melatonina Então os efeitos colaterais
que ela colocou na Live lá do betet Eu
particularmente nunca vi em muitos anos
usando melatonina então assim o pessoal
gosta de dizer que sabe muito porque lê
rodapé de livro né Não tô falando que a
quer não é um excelente profissional é
mas o pessoal sabe né usar essas
informaç de rodapé para impressionar as
pessoas e e fazer um marketing pessoal
aí de criar autoridade né então fiquem
atentos só com essas coisas porque aí no
caso da Live lá do Juarez provavelmente
ele falou ampassã lá que a vitamina C
ela aumenta absorção no cérebro por
causa das Bombas iônicas do sódio
potássio
E por aí vai aí ficou essa filigrana no
ar aí entendeu que na prática não tô
vendo o que que isso vai mudar a vida de
alguém né entenda isso daí
né Essa só uma opinião tô nem criticando
o calegaro nem criticando
a respeito muito os dois tanto calegaro
quanto a Lu tá só tô dizendo para vocês
não ficarem muito presa filigrana tá a
coisinha pequena aqui na prática não
muda
nada bem ninguém mais se manifestou aqui
eu acho que tá na hora de encerrar esse
vídeo
né bem vou esperar até dar 40 minutos
deixa eu ver se tem algum vídeo alguma
pergunta nova no
documento ah
tem mais pergunta
aqui jovem come dois ou três biscoitos
recheados por dia com leite F faz anos e
muito perigoso Estou preocupado sou
viciado em
açúcar quem que é o jovem
você não sei se eu entendi essa ve isso
aqui isso aqui é que é um desabafo é uma
pergunta que que é
isso Não entendi
ah
Ah tá aqui Antônio Renato que tá falando
aqui Sou viciado em açúcar Estou
preocupado quais perigos eu tenho deixa
te falar uma coisa Antônio ten a coragem
e pare de consumir açúcar tira o açúcar
da sua vida você vai sofrer uns dias aí
você vai tomar café sem açúcar vai tomar
suco sem açúcar no começo vai estranhar
muito e vai sofrer mas depois você vai
acostumar aconteceu isso comigo tá faz
esse passo aí tenha coragem de fazer
isso aí tá perigos perigos são vários
vai te inflamar o açúcar vai te provocar
aumento de risco de infarto de
AVC de câncer de doenças crônicas em
geral de
osteoartrite de Ach porose o açúcar um
veneno tá se você consumir de vez em
quando tudo bem mas tira o açúcar da sua
vida do seu dia a dia só o óleo de coco
é eficaz para acabar com a caspa nem
sempre Robson Nem
sempre eu falei da vitamina C e magnésio
no cérebro po ser muito caro treon ah
não mas você tava falando de aumentar a
absorção de vitamina C no cérebro não
foi isso você tá fazendo uma confusão Eu
acho né porque o magnésio treonato é
caro
mas a vitamina C não vai aumentar a
absorção de magnésio do cérebro não era
isso tá querendo dizer que a tua
pergunta não era essa não aqui
ó ó você colocou aqui ó disse que
vitamina C combinada com sódio potássio
cálcio magnésio penetra no cérebro
entendi que você estava falando da
vitamina C né você tava falando da
vitamina C Então você tem que formular
melhor
pergunta tá
por você colocou sódio potássio cálcio e
magnésio Vamos pesquisar isso eu nunca
ouvi falar que vitamina C aumenta a
absorção de magnésio no cérebro vamos
ver mas é que você formulou maior
pergunta
vamos lá vamos ver isso
aí
ô caramba
m
olha não achei nada não viu não vi
evidência nenhuma que essa mistura de
vitamina C
sódio potássio vai aumentar absorção de
de magnésio no cérebro não mas eu vou
ver o vídeo depois do betet aí tá bom
eu tô olhando aqui num nos artigos
científicos não tô achando nada disso
não eu acho que talvez seja uma confusão
aí ou sei
lá deixa eu olhar no outro lugar aqui
tô olhando em artigos científicos
não tô achando nada a respeito disso não
tá depois eu vejo o vídeo lá do do
calegaro Então tá pessoal boa noite para
vocês também bom descanso até a semana
que vem um abraço a todos aí